du
ils n'étaient pas mis là bas ils avaient
cessé d'y passer ses week-ends et ses
vacances et pourtant il en était le
meilleur ambassadeur
avec la chanson le loir-et-cher en 1977
le chanteur rendait hommage à la sologne
de son enfance à dhuizon le village de
son grand-père et à la ferté saint cyr
la ferté saint cyr où il avait acheté
avec sa famille un terrain pour y
construire un chalet qui avait brûlé au
milieu des années 70 un incendie qui
avait comme anéanti les souvenirs
d'enfance de michel delpech
pourtant cette sologne mystérieuse et
reposante
il avait arpenté du matin au soir été
comme hiver
et cette terre de gibier l'ue avait déjà
inspiré en 1974 le chasseur une chanson
dans laquelle bien des français
s'étaient retrouvés
je
sur soa jeu
la sologne ce natif de la région
parisienne la portait en lui et il l'a
rendue populaire auprès de millions de
français
avec ce talent inimitable pour capter le
parfum des années soixante dix ans
aja
la chandelle
il y a
ma
eca
à jeu